what is up everybody happy friday i'm so
glad to see you
that you've tuned in i see that there's
at least 500 of you guys waiting to tune
in
i don't think you're here to see me
you're here to learn from our guests on
today's show
so without further ado let's jump right
into it today
we're going to be talking about how to
create
a 3d poster and there's a little hint in
the background there
and if you're not familiar with my guest
today you probably have seen
some of his work somewhere because i've
been referencing his work for some time
long before we've reached out to him
check out his beautiful work taking
beautiful
3d geometric shapes and integrating them
into these wonderful designs and posters
very minimalistic in their nature very
subdued color palette just
gorgeous rendering look at this
that's awesome you know what's even
cooler jonah what's that
you can actually even buy these prints
and hang them up
inside your home or your office and i
think i need to get some prints myself
please
comps look at these dude look at this i
might just steal those and put them in
mine
okay well i didn't know this but he also
runs a full service design studio
in pristina pristina kosovo hopefully i
said that right i feel like i'm
butchering a lot of words today and he's
also worked with clients like microsoft
tedx toyota jaguar land rover just to
name a few
if you guys go to his website if you're
just joining us you don't know what's up
go to deepyellow.net that's deep
yellow.net
and you can see some of his work i'm
gonna switch over to this jonah if you
can just
help me show some of this jonah right
there we go really look i'm gonna click
on this identity system check this out
guys oh it's not showing your
website or whatever it's showing your
screen or your second desktop oh i see i
see okay
so we'll we'll cancel that for right now
we'll go back to this i'll deal with
that later but you can see
his work here i just really like the
geometric
simplicity the clean clean layout just
beautiful stuff
and this is the identity system i wanted
to show you but i hadn't mirrored my
screen properly okay you know who we're
talking to today we're talking to nerto
muhajiri and you guys can go to
deepyellow.net
or follow my instagram at deep shape
nerto welcome to the show man
[Applause]
all right for having me in the show man
you are super pro
and you've prepared for this so i love
this and i just want to wet the appetite
of everybody tuning in
this is not one of those super talky
ones we're going to talk a little bit
we're going to find a little bit about
the man behind the work and his studio
how he does what he does and there's
wonderful resources he's shared with
everybody if you guys go check out his
website
but we're also going to get to see you
design and build a poster live is that
true
yeah it is basically i'm very excited to
share my
process and creative thinking through uh
3ds max and in photoshop
so we'll go through we'll go through
that
okay so 3d studio max are you using any
kind of special rendering engine
yeah i'm using v-ray v-ray okay that's a
popular
engine for rendering that works with a
lot of silver
actually so before we talk about this
one project and i saw it on your website
and i'm going to get to it in a second
i want to get a little bit about your
background you're a man of mystery
because i'm trying to find information
about you it's very hard to find
anything about you
tell me a little bit about your
background what did you study how did
you get into doing what it is that you
do today
yeah first of all i was a
kid with a dream to be an architect
and i started architect in high school
and
later in the university but in the
meantime i was working as a graphic
designer
like i was doing both of them and
the rendering part that is connected to
deep shape now was
early on my career like an
architect when i did renderings and
stuff and later on
later on i continued my career in
graphic design
so i stopped working in architecture
because graphic design work was suiting
me
more and now everything is connected so
i'm connecting dots
with the experience that i have in
architecture and graphic design now
with dim shade do you miss any part of
the architecture
that you studied
i i don't miss that all because right
now
my girlfriend is running she's running a
studio
architecture studio so i'm always
helping
with rendering and architecture
ideas and stuff so i got back into it
well i think i have a few friends who
are architects they're going to be very
excited about tuning in
seeing you going from the architecture
side to the graphics side because
usually i'm always talking about
graphic design as it relates to
architecture okay now i want to get into
this one project because
i saw it on your site tell me about the
microsoft
project what is this all about yeah well
this is the more the biggest project
that i had with deep shape
deep sleep is a project that i'm doing
these shapes for
three years now and kind of this
microsoft project was the biggest
opportunity that i have
and and the the idea was
that microsoft reached me out one of the
creative directors of microsoft
we were liking each other's work in
instagram
and and he had this opportunity to do
some geometric shapes or
a language more of a language of
microsoft
azure ai like microsoft artificial
intelligence
so these shapes are connected more to
developers and how they do stuff
and and this is more of a language
that we did so
you actually got a client lead from your
instagram account
yeah okay everybody honestly asked me
how do you
where did you get this client so
basically instagram is is the most
uh community stuff
do you get most of your job leads from
instagram
not mostly but deep shape related works
i got
mostly from instagram but now microsoft
this is
going to to give me more opportunities
and
more clients i think i think so too and
if you guys are admiring this work go
check out his instagram it's a deep
shape
and maybe this time we should get a
little bit into your poster process
because i think
we're going to learn a lot of stuff from
you so perhaps it's time for me to stop
sharing and jump into it but before i do
before i do that
i want to let everybody know he's a very
generous guy
he is naruto is a very generous guy if
you guys go to deep yellow.net
there are a bunch of mock-ups that you
can download that he's he's prepared for
you
totally for the amazing price of free
free
and if you're loving the artwork you can
go to redbubble.com we'll drop the links
in the description below and you guys
can go check out his work there
and purchase a couple of prints all
right let's let's stop this and i will
turn over
the show to you okay i start sharing my
screen now
okay yeah and joe and i
got my other screen ready now just in
case we need it so we are seeing my
screen
we are we see this beautiful deeper
background
yeah it's fresh and we'll start with 3ds
max
okay i have i have my the latest version
of 3ds max and we are going to
be playing uh with uh
f letter so i wanted to to decide to do
something with
with the future i love that
yeah so you guys will be more
connected and we are going to do this
together
right now what kind of what you inspired
was was
the future logo
okay was this f letter this quarter of a
circle
so i was inspired by this one and
and maybe we're going to do a lot of
exploration
in that shape this is quarter of a
circle
ok ok
okay so uh
we'll we will not go into details but
we will we are going to share more of a
creative process
all right and how how i do these shapes
and the lighting and shadows and
the position of the cameras and all the
stuff
so we are going to create a tube
and how do i get rid of the
zoom all of your cameras
i don't know but we're seeing your
screen okay okay
don't worry about that yeah i minimize
that okay
so this is the 3ds max basically it's
pretty good solver on the right side you
have all of the
create panel where you can create uh
shapes simple shapes that i start
working
usually so for now we are going to use
this
tube and you can control a lot of things
so for now we are using
the slice
of the letter f wow that was fast
yeah okay
so we will make sure that we have
uh more subdivisions
so when we're rendering it's gonna be
smooth enough
and for now i'm going to duplicate this
shape
with an instance so when i move
something
on the top it will impact also
the second one
okay so there are there are two views
that usually get
in 3d there is a perspective
but i always look for the
for the the one that has that
that has not this kind of angles you
know
i always look for the graphic design
view
this one i go from graphic design
and look in that way
like this
and for now i'm moving
and getting this letter f as you can see
and also the height and and the and the
width of the shape so now i'm making
the rectangle here so
we are going to make sure that we have
more simple shapes in this
okay and we'll make the
dimensions of the artwork
some rendering settings
how big do you typically render these
images at
excuse me how big do you usually render
the images at
usually they they don't take long
because i don't have
a reflection and all the kind of
inspired will
lower the speed of the rendering
we can see it now i'm just making the
the the poster the dimension of the
pulse here
so now we are doing the
doing the poster now while you're doing
that jonah did you notice that nerdo's
um microphone got a little muffled
what happened there he might be talking
closer to the computer or something
if something is up with your audio you
know
okay it's better now yeah it's better
there yeah
what are the dimensions of the render
that's what i was asking you
yeah the dimensions are one thousand and
two hundred with one thousand six
hundred
okay well they are pixels
pixels dimension but not gigantic
and basically uh for now i will just
make a
test render to see what we are doing
so we'll we'll go through the language
settings
there are some presets like interior
and studio setup
material for now now did you set up
lights already are there
just default lights and
i usually set up lights we're gonna set
up the lighting now
i see and
for the lighting that i usually have
is positioned on the top of the shapes
like for this one position on the right
top
so always always is on the top side the
lighting or the shapes
this one as you can see
you're saying now when we position the
light in there
so this is the line
and we're gonna set up the the
base where this shape is going to stand
with this one
is that a big area light that you're
using
what is that a big area light
no no there's no any other light than
this one that i
put right now yeah but what kind of
light is that
this is a light from v-ray uh-huh
because
v-ray this plug-in has its own lights
so this is the light uh normal light
with normal
okay so we can hear the render just to
see what we are doing
is this a ray trace image
yeah this is uh probably the rendering
is taking along
i'm gonna reduce the
set some settings
what about the material that you're
using the shader for the object itself
is there anything that you're using
that's custom yeah for now the material
is not
set up yet
material for now it has just the color
but later on we are going to implement
the v-ray material
is going to look better i see
okay so i'm reducing some of the
rendering
settings
okay people on the internet on youtube
are saying they're having a hard time
hearing you right now so we want to be
able to hear you
so either you say it and i can repeat it
or maybe we somehow change something
because we want to make sure people can
hear you
what do you think we should try are you
hearing me now
i can hear you okay sometimes it gets a
little muffled for some reason i can't
figure out why that's happening
and if not then we go back to the
earpods and deal with a little feedback
but
yeah we can try okay
okay okay so glory is gory tv is asking
what software is this
he's using 3d studio max he's running
this on a pc and he's
rendering it using v-ray so for all the
people who are checking out the
technical specs there that's what we're
doing
he's used some very primitive shapes uh
one one light
one normal light and we haven't done
anything with shaders or anything yet
he's just doing some quick tests
yeah so for now i'm
decreasing the the light intensity
because it's blown out up there huh yeah
it's blown out
yeah and there's no ambient light right
now right
so people are asking what kind of
computer are you using
actually now i'm in my macbook
using windows as you can see oh my god
you're using a macbook running windows
yeah i've never heard of that
very few people actually do that wow
okay so you're running some kind of pc
emulator software to be able to run
3d studio max yeah it's i'm using
bootcamp
uh-huh it's it's not parallel on desktop
it's
it's installed basically okay
do you typically use the macintosh for
your work
uh no macintosh i use
only for browsing and stuff and lately i
lately lately i got this
touch bar and this laptop yes and
but for now the windows the touch bar is
not working
so it's just the function keys i see
maybe later that was a burn
right there guys for all you apple fans
how's such a barney only uses the mac
because they're so underpowered
just for surfing and the touch strip
okay so this is the thing with the
exposure
that you do so this is the trick
that you remove the highlight burn
have you seen that no okay show it to me
again
oh what is that slider because i can't
really see my eyes are not that good i'm
kind of old here
what's the slider this is the exposure
settings it's kind of mini photoshop on
the
on the previous maps
settings
wow okay okay hold on the audio
it got a little bit better but now it's
like really staticky with some pops on
it
my goodness we're struggling with audio
today guys hang in there we're going to
get him
to watch him work here and i'll try my
best to explain what what nurture is
saying to us
but hopefully the mic improves here so
he's
adjusting the exposure setting inside of
3d studio max
and it's similar to the way that
photoshop works so he was able to get
rid of the hot spot
and you can change the hue and the
saturation and do a bunch of things in
there
yeah they're saying the audio is a
little crackly
seeing this render is so satisfying
isn't it jonah
we haven't he just got started too
maybe you can disconnect the the airpods
uh it's now you sound like a robot
like ig 88 or somebody or something
no it's horrible
we don't know what's going on
and now it's the noise no
it's still it's not that noise it's like
you sound like you're underwater in a
computer
transmitting from outer space
okay why don't you say something again
let's see if it's any better
no no hang in there guys hold on we're
gonna work out this audio
people are saying r2d2 no it sounds more
like ig 88 right
or that probe the probe in empire
strikes back when it's like
[Music]
oh this is some pretty cool like lucas
uh what is that called
thx sound effects here skywalker studio
sound effects
built-in
you see that
[Laughter]
i'm going to try to remain upbeat here
as we're trying to work through this
technical challenge guys they're saying
plug it in
somebody's like i'm not buying a mac
after this that's not the problem
everybody here runs the macintosh
including me my audio sounds fine
okay rj saying leave the zoom and then
come back again
no it's not
this is like um is that the verizon
commercial can hear me
you can hear me now yeah
it's terrible okay so let's try this
natto why don't you uh
leave this zoom and come right back and
see if that will help somebody's
suggesting that and we'll try that we'll
try anything because we got to hear you
and i'm like we're getting really into
this and we can't hear you so
let's let's step out and let's try it
one more time okay
or i could just try and guess at
everything that you're doing all right
for you
there you go okay so guys
hang tight i'm gonna go back to my deck
then maybe jonah yep
no you know what let's look at his work
that's what i wanted to do let's do that
so if you guys go to deep yellow.net
while we're waiting for nerto to come
back
this is an identity system that he did
wow it's really nice stuff
just with such simple shapes too
hence deep shape is not a shallow shape
jonah deep shape
it's a deep shape very deep
philosophical isn't awesome
so let me go back to his work so you
guys can go and check out his website
but you know what i'm going to show you
the mock-ups
i think the two latest mock-ups are
missing a preview or something
but there are a bunch of mock-ups here
that you guys can download and use for
free
that's it hundreds of thousands of
people have already done it
so here's the five poster mock-up i
think
uh-huh look at that nice yup
super easy to use take your posters
there's a lot of missing images for some
reason
or maybe that's just my computer i am
running this on a mac guys
doesn't have a good reputation right now
well or does it everything that's on our
side is working just fine
thanks yes
indeed here's another project
a little ui ux going on here
uh there's the architectural influence
there right there look at that look at
that image
it all makes sense now
jonah you're monitoring it to see if he
can get in is he like in the there he is
hello waiting from the mute
no it's peaking maybe it's your mic
setting is just too hot
can you adjust the mic setting yeah okay
so adjust it down maybe so it doesn't
clip it's peaking that's all it is
but we're glad that we can hear you
again okay
there we go did you do it getting warmer
it's getting better it's getting better
right
oh and then it peaks i don't know why
and now it's just better still hot a
little hot
hot i don't know why no
oh too low i was too low but i still
hear that crispy nose that crackling
sound
i don't know no
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
okay we know who to call we need some
skywalker sound effects
yeah they're just on zoom getting these
sound effects
are hearing me now right yes we can hear
you again yes
okay let's go before everything breaks
again
we can hear you okay perfect yes
it's actually the clearest we've been
able to hear you so far all right
everybody welcome back to the show we're
talking to
nerto muhajiri and he's uh better known
as deepshape on instagram
we're back thank you for your patience
everybody
a little sweat here but uh we're okay
we will continue with the materials for
the poster
and we will pick some colors
so this is basically the v-ray material
so the materials of the v-ray plug-in
we are using the v-ray basic material
and
we will put a lighter
gray and we will just drag and drop
on the shape and we'll create another
material for the background
okay
with the blue color of the future of
course
now are these shaders part of the v-ray
package or these ones
you've built they are part of the v-ray
i see and is there a name for the
shaders you're using
the shaders are they don't have
the name or something but they are the
array
okay they have v-ray settings
so we are playing here and the rendering
is
fast enough just to give us
more uh
room for change and stuff
it's kind of cool off right yeah it's
looking good already
okay so you asked me before that the
reviews were ambient lighting so
i don't use uh ambient lighting i use
only the lighting over lights that are
inside the scene okay so for now
i'm going to create another light in the
opposite side
right but not instance
so whatever whatever you copy on the 3ds
max you have these
options to when you make it instance you
change
both of them so i'm just creating a copy
because the intensity
will be more lower
so this is the opposite lighting and i'm
making sure that
is invisible and decreasing the
intensity perhaps
and for now i'm using this world view
on the top of the screen but you have
these
this direction so i don't use cameras
i use this
[Music]
this global of orientation
i have exact 45 degree angle
i say yeah and now we
will just see how it looks
but usually when i design shapes i
i go back to my instagram and
see the colors so i will not go
too saturated or different in style
so we'll see what we are doing
so we can control also the saturation
with the frame here so it's better it's
more like
can you see now it's better yeah
but maybe we'll go out of guidelines but
we will see that for now
this needs a little bit contrast
i'm changing the background just to see
this is better right yes okay
we'll see the same result with the
inverse of color so i'm
multiplying all the stuff so we have
these
poster scenes here and here
and we'll see
the difference
so you duplicated the geometry in the
scene and now you're going to try some
other variations
yeah okay they will not impact so we can
see how they look
actually in this
look
they look great right mm-hmm okay
let's put materials
here
so we have we have the opposite
you just swap the colors yeah
you know what jonah i think seeing this
process
is the visual equivalent to asmr
definitely definitely
now we just need some asmr okay
excuse me please please give me some
let me let me just do this
okay
we will jump on other views so we are
almost finished with the
with this perspective of the shape
and we will continue to explore more
angles
for this one you know it's really nice
when you see the color bleeding
and bouncing back to each other yeah
that's so cool
okay now
we will try to to make
the opposite view now we were here
we're going to be there
right it's the same it's the same shape
but different angle oh
let's move to that
now have you linked the lights to the
geometry so they don't affect
each other no no
okay because they are not that
near to each other they will not affect
each other
the intensity is very low we have
some of the funniest fans that are
watching they're like asmr we need a
separate youtube channel
and somebody's saying stop at your
creeps and somebody else is saying
please whisper to me chris
and somebody else that has no idea what
asmr is so i'm gonna
i'm gonna google that for you
so i'm rotating
this
okay this is the view that
we are going to take so we don't have
these
these rectangles
with different
different view so we are moving
now on the dimensions and the axis
remove also the lightings
right because you like the lighting on
top right yeah
and we'll see now
as you can see now the light is blocking
the sea
and i'm making them light invisible
this is going to be the 200 poster
that i'm going to post on deep shade
instagram
oh nice nice
yeah we have
199 200
it's a special moment jonah it really is
i'm very very excited to see the final
post
as you can see here i always look for
these
differences on colors
and shapes
these highlights
so everybody who's joining us right now
you're late to the party
but we're talking to nerto muhajiri
and he's also known better known as deep
shape on instagram
software he's using is 3d studio max and
he's using that in combination with
v-ray
showing us his creative process and by
the time we're done with this today
this is going to be up on his instagram
account so i hope you're
enjoying this
okay now we are going to try something
different
you know when you inverted it it looks a
little it feels a little like facebook
now all of a sudden
i'm just trying to rotate this shape
on the different
lioness lilo is saying he looked at the
or she looked at the price of autodesk
and
my purse made the windows shut down
noise
3d studio max is not cheap it's a very
powerful piece of 3d software
yeah and for the mac users it is
maya called the rpgas
yeah you can use maya you can also use
cinema 4d there's a
but there's a bunch of options out there
some somebody was wondering can i do
this in
adobe dimensions now that would be a
feat i'd like to see that
okay i'm removing the background and
i want to do something challenging here
uh i'm
trying to to have one shape in this
view and the other on the other view
that
we had so we have two perspectives okay
two perspectives yeah we have this one
and we have the other one that is
from this perspective okay
all right so while norton's setting that
up
mj is asking me uh are you just as happy
in your normal life
i think i am i think i am
jonah would you agree or disagree i
would
have no choice but
you sir are correct
you can be more right so mark anthony is
saying
he thinks he can do this in dimensions
too and i know adobe's made some
significant progress with adobe
dimensions and i'd love to see you do it
so that's a challenge for you mark
anthony when you figure it out please
let us know
and we'll have you on the show have a
conversation yes yes so this is the
difference that
i wanted to make so as you can see
now the shape is i'm using two views
look oh i see i see i see you're
blending them together i got it
so one's laying down one's kind of
standing up yeah it's one it's more
complicated
than this one before
okay let's see how it looks all right
while you're doing that i have to ask
you this question how often do you post
something on instagram
in the beginning i posted i tried to
post
daily but later on i i posted one
into three or four days but
later on i reduced the intensity
because i started working more on
other projects and now
i'm doing i'm back again and posting
tomorrow
i see that sounds fairly typical of
creatives on instagram at first you you
have to develop a habit
post very frequently to kind of learn
how to do this stuff and build an
audience and at some point you start to
pace out your posting to
everywhere every once in a while every
few days and and it sounded like
you got really busy with client work but
now you're back
you're back yeah
now now it's even interesting because i
got
the deep shape so this is a free time
project that i work
and later on uh companies starting to
contact me to present their
ideas
no that's awesome
something interesting is happening here
by tilting and floating some of the
shapes up
off the ground plane you're creating
cast shadows and you're
also allowing light to sneak under and
bounce off the bottom
yeah really neat yeah
how long does it take you to make one of
these typically
uh sometimes ten minutes
sometimes one hour two hour maybe
sometimes never i'll just
leave it and do something else
and also making them tilted like this
creates this frozen moment in time it
feels like
something was tumbling or falling and
then you just stopped it
and then there's that moment i like it
[Music]
but still we have some lower
intensity columns maybe we need more
light
all right but we'll continue to develop
more
so we have
two or three viewers now
i'm going to read this comment from
mihai he's like for people who are
interested in doing 3d for free or can't
afford
the software packages use blender which
is an open source
and obviously you would have to invest
in a great computer but if you keep your
your objects simple like what you're
doing right now because you should be
able to manage this on almost any kind
of computer
the idea is that the shapes are very
simple so you can do
with a lot of greedy servers actually
so you just need the the knowledge you
want to put
lighting and stuff yes
so as you can see i'm always sticking to
one
right position
but it's not that for every shape this
light works
so for some shades you just need to
to position the lighting in another
download right right
okay so there's a question here from jer
he's asking
is it hard to make the jump i think from
architecture to graphic design
do they take you seriously as a graphic
designer having studied another
discipline
uh as i said before i was
working designs simultaneously while i
was studying but later on
i was introduced by some
uh typography and strength design in the
50s
and i remember watching norwexica
documentary so i was introduced more
into graphic design so
i kind of fell in love with the graphic
design
were you able to hear all of that that
was kind of hard to hear i wasn't
i didn't make it out too well okay so
you said you were introduced to graphic
design by something and then we couldn't
i don't know why but yeah it started out
good and then it just got really
muffled then go ahead can you hear now
yes i think so okay i'm i'm trying to
to increase my voice okay
as i said before uh i
i in the in the time that i was studying
i got a job as a web designer and
starting
exploring ideas and and the
design techniques so i was more involved
in geographic design
and i kind of fell in love with graphic
design
in that time and i was also making
money easily with graphic design and
this was the this
this one was the main idea to jump
so it sounds like it wasn't that
difficult for you to switch over
not not that much yeah but usually
i miss the architecture right
so i do want to share this with our
audience once you learn how to design
something you should be able to design
everything
so you can take the same principles of
scale
form balance contrast repetition
and take them into different disciplines
of course there's a little bit of a
learning curve obviously
but that's what it means to be a good
designer you should be able to design
anything
yeah and also and also what i did was i
just
connected the dots the knowledge that i
had earlier with
graphic design and with the
3ds max so
i just use that knowledge and
combining these these things
okay so pay you she's asking wait is
this the future academy why are you guys
live on this channel
okay so piyush welcome to the future
academy we have
not just one but we have two channels
one is dedicated to
just featuring artists like uh nerto
and we we cover things like logo design
typography
rendering retouching whatever it is
that's creative
the main channel is for the business
mindset stuff okay
so just so you know
we are just trying different thing here
okay so we're stepping away from the
original shape and composition
and you're mirroring them yeah we have
this
form in the middle as you can see
we'll just let's see how it looks this
one
yeah okay so i i know i'm dating myself
here
but when i got to school in 1995 the 3d
programs and the software and the
rendering
was not what it is today not even close
so the reason why i mentioned the color
bleeding into each other because
you guys take it for granted today that
the software does that for you
but back in the day we'd had to kind of
figure out tricks and
add spotlights to create the color spill
the color
bouncing back and forth to create more
believable realistic renderings
so you guys have a good now is what i'm
saying because back in the day
yeah yeah now it's easy
now now it's about the artist right it's
less about the tools and it's about the
artists like what what kind of
what do you want to say what how do you
want to express yourself and
these little adjustments that you're
making is through the eyes of an artist
and i like that i do what i do
sometimes i remove the shadow from the
base base material like
from this white background i just hit
properties and
remove the shadow so this
will not get the shadow so the shape
will be floating
this will make it more graphic design
like i have seen
yeah gosh it's such a shame that we
don't have an
awesome mic for you because uh we're
missing so much of like what you're
saying
and but i'm still just entranced
mesmerized by the visuals that you're
creating right now
same right so we're going to power
through this everybody hang in there
with us
it's so good joe are you going to learn
a 3d program after this dude i want to
learn c4d after this good
it's included in the adobe creative
cloud
okay this one is nicer
i mean i want to learn 3d again so this
is a it's very exciting
it's not that hard
so what are you doing now now i'm
exploring another angle is this fairly
typical for you to do this where you
have an initial idea and you try angles
mirroring objects changing things
floating things
okay yeah so how do you decide which one
you want to use
i don't know i decide which one
is better with the unique uniqueness
of those shapes so i always see the
the geometry
like if it has more simple shapes
i keep it like for this one
we'll try just to connect these surfaces
and do it as one
so we can control this
as you can see okay
uh there's some debate here is whether
or not cinema 4d is included in adobe
creative cloud
cinema 4d lite is included as far as i
know
double check guys somebody tell me
c4d lite which is everything that you
need to do what
naruto is doing right now
now she is saying it is included
now i'm trying to to get some f
first letter f lines
but still is going to look more like s
mhm
let's try and get the shadows back
i'm on the edge of my seat here
waiting with baited breath we will try
something
here we will remove
some polygons and go into the inside of
the shape
i see you have some other prints in the
background there those are huge
yeah are those special eyes or the can
we order those from redbubble that same
size
yeah you can you can order them you add
them
and i think they're printed on canvas
right
yeah yeah see jonah
my family oh something happened all
right
[Music]
what's the design in the creative scene
in pristina kosovo
we have a lot of agencies here
a lot of designers and developers
actually for the
country that we have small but we have a
lot of
creators here that's cool the first one
i
heard you say that i thought you said we
have a lot of asians here
really i didn't know a lot of asian
seas
all right so how many more of these will
you do before we jump into
photoshop uh maybe
we are at the ending but
we are at the ending of the exploration
okay
and we're also the audio's junking out
on us again
can you say something again you might
have to like log in and log back out
again i don't
okay yeah something is jacked up again
with the audio i don't know what is
going on
that macintosh is not our friend today
or maybe because it's prevailing against
the pc
emulator
um
okay so we're nearing the end of the
exploration here in 3d studio max for
everybody's tuning in late
and we're gonna probably be making this
transition pretty soon to photoshop
it may require us to bounce out of zoom
once
more and come back so we can hear
nurture as he speaks but
yeah yeah okay so we'll do that and
jonah and i will entertain the masses
while we wait for you to come back
oh gosh this is the first time we've
ever had something like this happen
jonah
and in times like this what do you
suggest we do jonah we read some of the
comments and do some more asmr
we can do that the return of the robot
voice yes
all right you guys have some questions
go ahead and drop it in the comments and
we have this rare moment where i'm able
to talk to you a little bit more
and then than i am usually because our
guest
has to leave and then rejoin us in a
second
let's see what are they saying what have
you really seen
let me tear this piece of paper
ah was that satisfying super satisfying
do you really like this asmr stuff jonah
i think i think it's funny
oh my head is a mouse quick it causes
the hair to rise for on people's necks
sometimes
it's called ear tingle apparently oh wow
yeah so
they want us to do a course on
topography using asmr
oh yes i know
yeah while we creep everybody else out
[Laughter]
could you hear that john yeah i could
unfortunately
okay guys we'll stop we'll stop people
are gonna leave
we apologize
they're like no we're trying to
entertain you guys all right what can
what can we do is nartel back
coming back all right so unmute yourself
interesting are you hearing right now
we are i think we're good like every
time you come back we're good for like
20 minutes
and then we're good yeah and i have a
limited time
[Laughter]
okay so you're the base of the
of the f's right yeah they're hollow now
oh no they're like cookie cutters
okay so for now
we are going to make the final
renderings
of the all of the forms that we had
let's start with the first one and make
it
final yep and i think you said 1200 by
1600
yeah yep
okay all right let's see how our little
macintosh computer is going to hold up
here
said that normally you work on a pc
though right
yeah and what kind of pc do you use give
us the specs
i have i had a dell
precision like workstation
laptop and before that laptop i had
an imac oh yeah
and i'm gonna guess
okay one down
yeah let's save this
so that render did not take that long
that was only like a minute
render that
okay we'll see and do
with the different materials
all right while he's doing that let me
just check the comments and see what
everybody's thinking or saying
people are saying this is the funniest
and edu most educational stream ever
we have to improvise the show must go on
as they say
all right so people want me to answer
questions now huh
jonah what's a good question oh man i
am not looking oh okay
let's see here
jesse's asking what is the biggest
poster design trend in 2020
i'm not gonna answer that question i've
asked it because
why do we worry about trends and what's
the importance of it
once you recognize that a trend is here
it's already too late just do what you
think you like
make something that you feel happy to do
every single day
christina is asking chris are you still
designing and what do you enjoy the most
i do design but not as much as i used to
and i mostly just make the thumbnails or
i help out with the critiques
that's the extent of what i design in
terms of hands-on because we don't do
client work anymore
i think this one is the best you like
this one the best
yeah so
it has two two types of
positioning of the shapes
some people missed it but they are
asking what did you do with the last
shape and i think what happened was you
removed the faces of the
form so you can see i removed yeah i
removed
these surfaces
and my hair so clean um
okay now he's taking the dip down
nice
okay let's just remove the highlight
burn
that's a number two rendering in the can
number three oh
number three i'm sorry number three and
we also had this one
that has this position
this one i like that one okay
sorry go ahead with shadows because i
did remove the shadows
did you learn i'm sorry did you learn 3d
studio max while in school or on your
own
on my own
as i was in the ninth grade
i was making renderings interiors
i wanted to make the ears look like i
see
yeah it always looks so much nicer when
you take
a design and you actually render it out
this way
i do like also this one
do you know the director joseph
kaczynski i think that's his name
he directed tron the remake the reboot
he was an architect
and yeah he was an architect and he
started doing
really beautiful hyper real 3d
renderings of environments
and i think as he was exploring that he
started moving the camera around
and then he would composite people in it
and eventually got picked up by
anonymous pictures which is david
fincher's production company
they started repping him for commercial
work and
he he got work um he uh
came up with this concept for the movie
oblivion
with tom cruise in it yeah
i think i think his name is joseph
because in c but somebody check it out
so if you take your passion
and you start to move into where it
crosses over into technology and
tell interesting stories there's no
limit to where you can go
[Music]
yeah so somebody's asking pitash kumara
is asking why did you stop doing client
work
we as a company elected to stop doing
client work in december
of 2018 many of you guys who have been
following
our story know this about the company
and we decided to dedicate all our
energy and effort
the entire staff to make content for
youtube to help teach you guys
and it's come at a little bit of a
financial
deficit for us because we made most of
our money doing client work
up until then but now thankfully many of
you guys are supporting us by buying our
products or
clicking on affiliate links or just
straight up donating money to us
so we appreciate that we'd like to
change the way we learn
and teach forever and i'm just talking
about us but
the entire education system so we're
investing every dollar
every cent that we have into trying to
innovate and create new learning models
for
all of you i can't help but to say this
every time it does these
passes at the rendering i love each
little pass
so the ambient occlusion pass the i
don't know if it's caustics but
all these little things that are
happening each and every pass looks so
gorgeous
i think that's like a credit to the
simplicity of the geometry
and the way that you've lit the scene
and just the way it's composed
yeah we also have this
nice lightning here
[Music]
i noticed when you created the shape and
they're telling that you didn't add a
bevel to the edges these are super sharp
edges right
yeah yeah
well if we make them the
mm-hmm but i'm not getting the
the shape inside as you can see
yeah i've lost some shadows there
let's see the lightning raised position
okay
we'll
move the lighting and see the difference
okay modak is asking what pc do you
recommend
for design
what do you think
i don't know if you if you work with
adobe illustrator
maybe the mac is the best
option or something yeah
i work with coral jaw and
the coral jaw lately is also on mac
but it wasn't i think
so the windows was always
better option to me yeah i don't know
that many people that use coreldraw
that's interesting
you're crowd draw guy huh
most of the companies here in kosovo
want they want to pull out
i didn't know that interesting
so the the answer is whatever computer
you can get your hands on
it doesn't matter i think i have this
conversation with my kids
no he's like dad there's like the new
macbook pro with the touch strip and
this and that
and they're going on and just just
lusting after that computer
and i said look this four year old
laptop that i have i can do more
creative work than you can and with the
fastest computer on the planet
it's not about the computer the machine
works just fine
i know so many people who are amazing
artists and you won't believe the
antiquated technology that they're
running it on
they use legacy software uh hydro 74 he
uses like some old version of adobe
illustrator like
like version five or something like that
he refuses the upgrade because he likes
it just the way it is
he doesn't need anything more than that
and so a lot of times we can go around
and chase the latest technology and the
software
mostly because they're crutches for us
because
we don't know how to use the tools
properly we're relying on too many undos
or
or fancy automatic processes so just
keep that in mind and the way that this
in crystallized for you is that
the camera never made the photographer
the the artist makes the tool it's not
the other way around the tool does not
make the artist
so you can give a camera and all
different kinds of power and technology
to 100 different people who are
untrained
and the true professional photographer
will still outbeat them all
because they're looking at light they're
looking at composition they know how to
make their subject matter feel at ease
or they just know
that at this time of day they need to be
in this position they're going to wait
for that shot
so there are many famous photographers
too who shoot on really old and
antiquated technology
you can you can beat the photographer
with a
photoshop like without going out and
taking the images
you know you can create the scene
and do it in in photoshop and
manipulating stuff and
beating the photographer for example
it's not that it's not the the
object that you use but it's the idea
that you have so if you have one idea
to implement it today it's very easy if
you have the right solvers
right so you're making adjustments to
lighting right now so that you can see
the forms because you're still losing
now you brought the bottom shape in i
could see that very clearly now
yeah we have some great photos here yeah
going on maybe are you turning into ao
or no yeah yeah
but you see these dirts here
maybe this one i will
use photoshop
so i use mostly photoshop or editing
instead
so now i notice you're also going in
adjusting exposure and all that i want
to be mindful of time here
we want to be able to see this completed
so we're at 12 16
and due to some unfortunate technical
challenges that we're having
uh nurtures working on his fourth render
i think
yeah yeah
we'll open the instagram and then
the photoshop and we'll go to program
and see
how the shape will work
joan i'm not gonna lie we're seeing
white on white like that just so nice
okay i think we will use
this one this one
all right
all right well we will use
all of them
okay a lot of people ask me for the
typeface
yeah two questions what software do you
use and what typeface
i use uh gp wall shrine
it's a typeface that i've chosen
because of the clean lines that has
numbers
okay
so this is my typeface that i use
so i notice in the shape here the one
that you've got up
it's got some twists to it and do you
take a basic shape and
deform it yeah yeah
okay i'll use bend and twist
bends our basic basic uh
modifiers like
or twist them
then we'll go and put
into frame
there it is
let's try something here
have you printed 3d models before of
your designs
no lately i
started
not from the beginning
i think some of them could make like
really cool sculptures for the desk or
something i don't know definitely
look at jonah dude i'm drooling over
this
[Laughter]
i expect you to learn cinema 4d by
monday jonah it is a three-day weekend
it is plenty of time
i do appreciate also that you've
mentioned it on your instagram
live for feed that or and change the
link for this thing
and that's really cool i wish more
artists that came on our show helped
us to promote and to bring their
audience in and watch as well
what are you doing now i'm exporting
the final design to be published in
instagram
just saving as a jpeg
is this process that you shared with us
any different than how you would do it
if nobody was watching
it it is the same process sometimes
i do it quickly sometimes it takes a
long time
to get the the shape
but this is basically the whole process
like trying to get the right angle
right lighting getting the right shadows
now you can try one of the other renders
yeah
do you know yet which one is your
favorite render
uh my favorite
is one that is not rendered
[Laughter]
hmm this is made in quran
oh
neat so people were asking that question
of whether or not this could be done
using photoshop or illustrator and
apparently it can be
if you understand if you know the
principles
some shapes can be done with
vector servers
well i mean i've seen people do photo
real illustrations
using illustrator all vector art
and it's amazing so yeah just this
look at this 220
graphics
okay so i saved these
you saved two already
will you post this as a carousel
yeah nice
this one is really nice but
maybe we can play a little bit with the
contrast
like this
so you added a little contrast there to
blow out the white
is highlighted
are you working in 8-bit color here just
out of curiosity
what colors are you working in an 8-bit
color are you doing
16-point oh what is it 16-bit floating
or any of these other fancy
a-bed yeah okay
so the rules multiply
and decrease the like this
oh
what'd you say jonah oh can you speak
up a little bit yeah there we go so i'll
remove that highlight
yep this is better
so this is how it was without photoshop
you kind of removed the highlight and
then you painted in the gray to flatten
it back out
right yeah yeah
so this is number three and we have
something about this it's like white
paper
on a white background so chris so sharp
so we will post this separately
so now how are you going to fix this
stamp
what is that error
i click something that's building
nice yeah
we will also remove this highlight burn
daiya is saying it's a one in the
morning in nepal and he's still
here
as you can see here chris i'm trying to
create a difference here because i lost
the
the difference of the faces
like they're blending together so you
want to create a little shadow there
to separate the shape from the
background right
and let's see how you do this you're
going to paint it in with a brush or
something else
um yeah so i see
mm-hmm will be lighter or darker
maybe lighter
maybe lighter better mhm
oh there it is yeah
these subtle little touches guys this is
what it takes
because straight out of the box the
geometry is doing something funny and
of course he's working pretty quickly to
show us what his process
so he's not finessing every little light
and angle just
the way he might have but sometimes it's
just easier to go into photoshop and
retouch it
i think what you're doing here naruto
can correct me
i'm wrong you're looking at the values
to make sure there's good separation
sometimes you go darker sometimes you go
lighter
so that the planes read
we also have an issue with the shadow
in the bottom of the shade yeah
yeah but
it would take a long time to fix that
because
it's it's a bit difficult yeah
yeah we understand so accept that
all the shadows are perfect
yeah maybe here we lost something
okay we are almost done here
ting ting is saying it's 9 30 p.m in
norway welcome
okay
we are done walls all right beautiful
job
okay so you're saying that uh if you if
uh it would take you a little longer
time to
uh finesse the shadow at the bottom
there just to get the separation that
you want but
for the sake of what we're doing right
now oh you're doing a little bit more
retouch there huh
okay so i think
we are going to post three
okay so not the shape the the first
three
yeah what do you think this one can be
one
closed and these two
excellent
apparently we have a bunch of people
from india watching and they're saying
it's 1am
i i can hear the audio clipping out here
so i think it's time for
us to almost wrap up the show it's zoom
saying we're done
we can't get any more
[Laughter]
pushing the limits of technology here is
what we do at the future
okay great job
okay so i guess when we all go and
follow you on
instagram at deep shape we'll be able to
see
okay all right uh let me now
switch over okay so i'm going to take
control here
and share my screen and wrap this up
here
all right let me get the screen ready
what am i doing
my brain's freezing here guys let me
share my screen
all right here we go
and
all right i want to thank everybody for
tuning in and watching
this demo i apologize for the audio and
going in and out i think there's some
technical problems that hopefully
won't happen to us in the future but i
do appreciate your patience but most of
all i do appreciate nurture
for coming on the show and i've been
following him for quite some time
referenced his work
on a couple occasions at least and so
i'm just so thrilled to have him on the
show and share
a little bit of his creative process you
guys can find more about him if you're a
client
go to deepyello.net you can find a bunch
of things
including for designers as well mock-ups
that are totally free and you can
download
them there and if you're a fan of his
work and you want to hang a piece of
artwork a piece of canvas on your walls
i imagine jonah's going to do this go to
redbubble.com we've already dropped
the link in the comments but we're going
to do them below as well
so check the links below this is who he
is nerdo muhajiri
and he's a deep yellow.net and at deep
shape you can follow him on instagram
thank you so much for doing this jonah
give us some music let's get out of here
don't forget everybody to like comment
and subscribe
and hit the bell for notifications and
you guys are all part of the 1 billion
mission that we're on to teach people
how to make a living doing what they
love
1b 1b minus one okay
thanks everybody for supporting us and
those of you guys that are in a place
that
you can afford to do so and want to
support us drop us a donation
at venmo this is dough i'm chris this is
our nation
thanks very much everybody